our next speaker will be Mr Robert
Spencer Mr you Mr Robert Spencer is the
us-based director of jihad watch a
program of the David horid Freedom
Center and author of 13 books on Islam
including two New York Times
bestsellers he has he has led seminars
on Islam and Jihad the United States
command United States Army command and
general staff College the US
Army big word a symmetric Warfare group
the FBI The Joint tourism task force and
the US intelligence Community he's a
weekly colist for PJ media and front
page magazine and has written 11
monographs and well under 300 articles
get thank you very much I wanted to call
your attention to a couple of
anniversaries one that just passed
recently and one that's coming up uh the
one that just passed was uh February
14th the 25th anniversary of the salon
Rashi death fatwa issued by the Islamic
Republic of Iran on and then coming up
on April 15th is the first anniversary
of the Boston Marathon Jihad bombings
now these anniversaries are obviously
related but they are related I think in
many important ways that it is key for
us to understand and to bear in mind
because they are two prongs of the
attack that we face today one is of
course Jihad violence and mass murder
which happens on a more and more
frequent basis every day somewhere
around the world the other is the
prohibition on speaking honestly about
its
cause which advances further all the
time in Australia in the United States
in Europe and in the rest of the world
these two things go closely together
they go hand inand they are
self-reinforcing and they are part of
the same overall attack
after the salon rushi fawa those of you
who may recall uh those days will
remember that there was a tremendous
International discussion and debate
about the nature and parameters of the
freedom of speech and almost universally
in the West on the left as well as on
the right there were Stout defenses of
the freedom of speech as a bullwark a
absolute indispensable pillar of a free
society and thus something that was not
negotiable and there was General
revulsion against the fatwa an rushy as
something that was inimical to a free
Society inimical to the principles of
Freedom Express of of expression and to
the Dignity of the human
person I recall in those days I went to
see a concert of uh the band 10,000
Maniacs you remember them and
uh there's a fan and Natalie Merchant
I believe was the name of the uh singer
and she was they had had a popular cover
of Cat Stevens song Peace Train Cat
Stevens in the meantime of course had
become a Muslim changed his name to
Yousef Islam and had endorsed the rashti
fatwa saying on the BBC when asked if he
would if he were dining in a restaurant
and Salon Rusty were at the next table
and an attacker came in would he protect
rushi and he said Not only would I not
protect him I'd bring up the Ayatollah
Ki and say he's right here and I'll hold
until you get somebody
here and so Natalie Merchant knowing all
that and hearing this the cries from the
crowd saying sing Peace Train Peace
Train she said no as long as now that
Cat Stevens has gone mad I will never
sing this song
again now fast forward 25 years later
just recently Katie Perry who you may
know is a contemporary singer I kind of
wish I didn't but nonetheless she came
came out with a music video featuring
for a second or two a man wearing a
pendant that had the name of Allah
written in Arabic on it and then the man
is burned to
death when a petition was started and
50,000 Muslims around the world signed
it demanding that ktie Perry take this
video down and apologize she immediately
complied and erased the Allah pendant
from the video The Descent from Natalie
Merchant to Katy Perry is very steep
and it is indicative of what we are up
against because what has happened in the
25 years since the rush fatwa after all
that indignation and defense of free
speech in 1989 is the total
collapse of a general understanding of
the necessity of free
speech and a general acceptance of the
idea that if Muslims are offended about
something then we better stop doing
it instead of reinforcing the ideas of a
pluralistic society and say you know in
a society where there are people with
different perspectives different values
different priorities there are times
when we're going to offend each other
and we're just going to have to take
that and live in peace that idea is out
the window and instead if something
offends Muslims then it has to go and
this of course happens at the highest
levels and brings back to the connection
with the Boston Marathon bombing and the
April 15th anniversary
several years before the Boston Marathon
Jihad bombing as uh actually it was just
read to you uh from this Podium a few
minutes ago I used to rather regularly
give training seminars to FBI agents to
Joint terrorism task force to various US
military groups and on occasion to the
CIA and then in
2010 after protest from the Council on
American Islamic relations which you may
know as a Hamas link Muslim Brotherhood
front group in the United States the uh
FBI and all the other agencies dropped
me and others like me as Trainers for
agents and scrubbed all terror
counterterrorism training materials of
any mention of Islam and
Jihad this was after this this
culminated actually in 2011 in a letter
from a uh Muslim lawyer Nam
faran who wrote a letter on behalf of 57
Muslim organizations in the United
States demanding that all counterterror
training materials and all counterterror
training never mention Islam and have
nothing to do with Islam or Jihad even
though that's obviously the primary
Terror threat that we Face the letter
was addressed to John Brennan who was
then a very high National Security
official in Barack Obama's
administration and is now the director
of the CIA Brennan immediately complied
in letter written a few days later on
White House stationary as if to
underscore that this was coming straight
from the top and Brennan said yes of
course we will eliminate all of this and
there will be no mention of Islam and
Jihad and this material that you find
offensive it will all be
gone and they
did not long after that Russian
intelligence agents contacted the FBI
and they said that there was a man named
Tamarin Sara
who was meeting with Jihad terrorists in
Chia and dagistan and that he lived in
Boston and they better keep an eye on it
and they warned more than
once and the FBI took a look at Terin
sonv and decided he was not a priority
and not a threat and he of course was
one of the two along with his brother
Boston Marathon Mass murderers last year
in the name of jihab
why did the FBI not take the Russian
warnings to Heart why did the FBI not
act on
them probably because in large part
they're not allowed
to they can't talk about this the
Russians said Tamar and Saray is is
meeting with
jihadis well what's a Jihadi according
to the FBI Jihad is an interior
spiritual struggle for the betterment of
the human person so they probably
thought well how nice
and any agents who were there who who
knew what Jihad was because they
remembered from the training that had
been scrubbed although Brennan did say
that every agent that got trained by me
and by others like me would be
re-educated chairman ma would have been
so
pleased and any of them that did
remember they were probably not able to
act not long before all this happened
there was of course the Fort Hood Jihad
massacre in Texas on a military base
where major nidal Malik Hassan a US Army
psychiatrist murdered 13
Americans while screaming Akbar and
after having handed out Kuran the
morning of the shooting and saying he
was about to do something great for
Allah and that of course has been
classified by the Obama Administration
as a case of workplace
violence I wish it were a joke but it's
true no major nidam Malik Hassan was a
major in the US Army and he had just
recently been promoted and yet a year or
two before his attack he gave Grand
rounds which is when the psychiatrist
the Army psychiatrists all get together
and one of them gives a lecture to the
others about new breakthroughs new
discoveries new advances in the
field nidal Hassan it came to be his
turn and he gave a presentation about
Jihad terrifying his colleagues and
raising the concerns of many of them
that came out later saying we thought he
was going to be violent and shoot people
and sure enough they turned out to be
right what did the Army do they gave him
a promotion and they gave him a
promotion with Top Flight topnotch top
level recommendations saying he's
performing excellently and we think that
army officers can benefit from his
insights into
Islam now were these people absolute
idiots were they
fools no they were people like you and
me who wanted to keep their jobs and
they knew what would have happened if
they had reported nid Malik Assan and
said this guy is preaching Jihad
violence when he's supposed to be
training psychiatrists this guy is
clearly somebody who is uh a great
potential danger and not only that of
course later it came out he was in touch
with anir alaki the Jihad leader and and
there were all sorts of other danger
signs but they knew that they couldn't
do that they knew they couldn't report
him because you can then imagine what
would have happened next the New York
Times would have had a story about
islamophobia in the military and Muslim
soldiers being hounded just for
expressing their
faith and the people who had been
responsible for the negative
recommendations you know what would have
happened to them they would have lost
their jobs they would have been publicly
humiliated they would have been raped
over the coals on C CNN and in Time
Magazine and in the New York Times and
Washington Post as racist bigoted
islamophobes and they would have been
lucky to be able to get a job out of
McDonald's after
that because McDonald's doesn't want
higher racists anymore than anybody else
so
look this
denial this refusal to accept the
reality of what we're facing this
inability to discuss it rationally
honestly and
fully it's murderous it kills it takes
lives we saw it in Fort Hood and we saw
it in Boston and it's a direct result of
something that started rolling at the
time of the rushy
fatwa the rushy fatwa was an assault on
the western otions of freedom of speech
and at that time people knew still that
freedom of speech was valuable but as
they kept pushing and kept on
relentlessly pressing against it and the
organization of Islamic cooperation
launched its worldwide effort to compel
Western Nations to criminalize criticism
of Islam under the guise of so-called
hate
speech our understanding of the freedom
of speech is eroded and we have without
even realized it internalized these
Sharia blasphemy Provisions that there's
something wrong with speaking critically
about Islam and Jihad and Islamic
supremacism and Islamic
terrorism and and the result is that 13
people are dead at Ford hood three
people dead in Boston hundreds killed
and mimed I mean hundreds wounded and
mimed all because we cannot speak about
this and we know what will happen when
we speak about it and I know because
I've spoken to many of you over the last
few days and encouraged you to speak out
yourselves and you say well you know I
have a job I lose my position they would
call me a bigot and a racist well of
course and you know why because they
know that that's what works that's what
they will say that will keep us from
being able to do anything but stand mute
and defenseless in the face of this
ongoing
threat it is absolutely imperative that
we recall the words of the American
Declaration of Independence that the 56
signers at the end of the document they
say to this great cause they say we
pledge Our lives our our fortunes and
our sacred
honor our sacred honor you know we don't
talk like that now in the 21st century
you we don't say you know my honor is
offended we only actually hear about
that in Islamic contexts with honor
killings and things like that but
actually our sacred honor is what
they're assaulting most
effectively because we all know and many
many people outside this room know full
well that to speak honestly about Jihad
violence means they will destroy you as
a person they will make make you
somebody that nobody wants to have
anything to do with somebody where if
you Google the name all these things
these terrible things come up most
people don't want to risk it but if we
don't then the Jihad will continue to
advance it's just that
simple if we don't take the risk and
allow our lives and fortunes and sacred
honor to be put at risk then our
children and our grandchildren their
lives and their fortunes and their
sacred honor will be drastically and
irrevocably
diminished the Islamic Jihad agenda is
for a purpose it is to make Islamic law
the law of the
land Islamic
law is a very very detailed complex of
laws that mandates the discrimination
against and second class status of women
and non-muslim Muslims and
others it is a law that if you criticize
it
then you immediately forfeit your right
to
live it is in other words a totalitarian
system a slow motion reign of terror no
less unmistakably A Reign of Terror than
the Reigns of Terror that we saw from
the Bolsheviks from the maist from
paulot it is no less A Reign of Terror
it's just one that is less dramatic and
one that is more
codified you know that if you step out
of line that if you do certain things
you will be stoned to death if you do
other things you'll be beheaded if you
do other things your hand will be
[Music]
amputated in the judeo Christian
tradition there is the idea of the
cultivation of virtue and the uh
development of the character of the
human being so that you choose what is
good and to reject what is not good what
is evil because it is evil because you
prefer the good to the evil The Virtue
that is inculcated by stoning by
amputation by beheading by those kinds
of threats that's not
virtue that is an Empire of
fear that is living your life too afraid
to step out of
line because you know what would await
you if you do that Empire of fear is the
society that our children and
grandchildren will grow up in and Live
and Die in as millions of Jews and
Christians and other non-muslims have
done in the 14th centuries that Islam
has
existed that is what we have to look
forward
to of course they are going to be
fighting of course they are going to
make it difficult for us the more of us
who stand up the less likely they will
be able to
succeed I still believe in order to end
on a happy note that human nature
will
never willingly accept
slavery and that we will not go gently
into the night and I can tell you one
one last story about another fored Jihad
attack in the United States at Fort
Dicks there was a a group of Muslims six
Muslims who were going to go into Fort
Dicks and shoot as many American
soldiers as possible before they
themselves were killed and then of
course they' go and enjoy the virgins in
Paradise the um plot was thwarted
because they liked to watch Jihad movies
beheadings uh shootings that kind of
thing bloody stuff and the problem was
they had them on VHS
tapes so they took them to the DVD store
and asked that they be transferred to
DVD this is a true story so that was a
17-year-old kid in the DVD store this
Clerk and he's transferring these tapes
from HS to DVD and he's seeing all this
blood and gore and hate and violence go
by and he realizes you know these guys
might be up to
something so he went to his manager and
he said
dude I'm seeing some really weird things
on these
videos should I go to the police or
would that be
racist now you see that sums up
everything I'm telling you today the
fact that the guy even thought for a
minute that's racist shows how insane we
have all let ourselves become and how
insane the society has become that he
would hesitate for a minute when he sees
Jihad mass murder and
bloodshed and he hesitates because he
knows already he's internalized the
lesson that the Islamic Republic of Iran
wanted to give us all with the rushy
fawa to oppose us is racist it's hateful
it's
bigoted and he he's grown up with it
he's breathed it in it's the air he
lives with so
the great news is he decided to go ahead
and be racist he turned them in and
they're in prison now his the better
angels of his nature went out and I have
every confidence I know that I'm
preaching to the converted in this room
because I know you're already energized
enough to be here but I encourage you to
take the next step and next time I'm
here next year in two or 3 years I hope
to come back and we'll have a Q society
meeting with all that part filled up and
people standing outside for much more
and that we will begin to make a
difference in Australian Politics as
well as in American politics and to turn
this around human beings are made not to
be slaves but to be free and this is the
great struggle between freedom and
slavery and the thing about slavery is
it's easy everything's set out for you
you know exactly what you have to do you
don't have to take any responsibility
you don't have to make any decisions you
just have to do what you're told let's
be better than that thank you